Hey guys it's Dr.Berg here in this
video I want to talk about the problems
with kale now as you probably have
already seen a lot of my videos on
promoting kale because kale is amazing
its anti-cancer anti-estrogenic
cleans up the liver it fixes the body
it's loaded with so many nutrients
vitamin A but it has a couple problems
okay for some people
not for everyone ok because a lot of
times people
it's convenient you take this you blend
it you drink it and you're good for the
day
so number one it can deplete iodine all
right but this really happens in people
with more hypothyroid problems
it's real simple solution just add sea kelp boom problem solved ok so that's
not a hard thing to do but number two
this is the big problem see your
microbes eat fiber you have four to five
pounds of microbes in your gut that live
on fiber
ok adding kale in a blender for some
people can overload the microbes to the
point where you get constipation or
bloating
if this happens switch it up
go to spinach you know steam it cook it
each other vegetables have salads
instead but don't keep going because if
you're constipated your bloated with
care too much fiber
you're not going to lose weight it's not
going to help you
you're gonna feel you're not going to
sleep that well so that's one of the
problems of this fiber is kind of a new
thing for a lot of people they're not
used to digesting it
so anything that is a sudden change all
of a sudden you're drinking 20 cups of
kale shake a day that's might be too
much for people so i always suggest go
small just start with one and gradually
increasing because you're my crops will
adapt over a period of time
I'm talking about not the majority maybe
twenty percent of population just can't
digest scale for the rest of us we can
digest it fine and it goes right in we
can no problem at all but if you get
constipation bloating switch up your
vegetables to spinach or salad
ok hope that helped I'll see you in the
next video